(manifestation)
SHAYAN ASGHARIAN
- J'ai jamais vu le peuple
iranien aussi en colère
que je les vois aujourd'hui.
- D'origine iranienne,
Shayan Asgharian observe
avec inquiétude la crise
qui secoue l'Iran.
- Je parlais avec une de
mes amies qui vit dans la ville
de Shiraz. Elle m'a dit qu'ils
nous coupent l'Internet encore.
- Le jeune homme de 21 ans
ne peut s'empêcher d'avoir
une pensée pour Mahsa Amini,
morte après avoir été arrêtée
an par la police
des moeurs.
- Elle a donné sa vie pour...
le droit de s'habiller
comme elle voulait.
(slogans)
- Mercredi après-midi,
des membres de la communauté
iraniennes ont exprimé
leur colère par centaine,
dans les rues de Montréal.
- Il faut que le gouvernement
canadien comprenne que cette
fois-ci il faut soutenir
le peuple iranien.
- Ça pourrait être ma fille.
On n'a pas la liberté, on n'a
pas la sécurité, la situation
s'est tellement empirée en Iran,
surtout, surtout pour
les femmes.
- Parmi les manifestants,
cette sociologue et politologue
née en Iran et installée
éal depuis plusieurs
années.
HANIEH ZIAEI, sociologue
- La population iranienne est
vraiment habitée par cette
colère sociale, qui elle-mqui ea
été construite sur une
frustruation socioéconomique
et politique.
- Un peuple divisé, un peuple
exaspéré, face à un régime quasi
impossible à déloger.
- Comment on s'en sort?
Bien écoutez, ça fait 40 ans
que ce régime gouverne.
En raison de cetten
étatique très, très forte,
à un moment donné, même
ces élans de révolte et de
manifestation sont vraiment
écrasés ouffés.ouffés.ouffés.ou.
- On sent tous qu'il y a
quelques chose qui est en train
de changer, tout le monde
le sent.
- À mesure que la colère
grandit, Shayan Asgharian
se laisse tout de même bercerpa.
- J'aimerais vraiment que
ce soit un pays démocratique,
qui a une constitution,
une constitution fait
par le peuple, pour le peuple.
Ici Hadi Hassin,
Radio-C